in this video we're going to multiply 36
times 27 so we're multiplying a
two-digit number times another two-digit
number and the way that we're going to
tackle it is we're going to first
multiply 36 times 7 and figure what that
figure out what that is then we're going
to multiply 36 times 20 figure out what
that is and then add those two numbers
together and what I want to do is first
to do this just show you the process for
how to multiply these two numbers and
then I'm going to do it again where
we're going to think a little bit more
about what the different numbers
represent so first let's start with the
process so I'm going to multiply 36
times 7 or 7 times 36 so I can start in
the ones place 7 times 6 is 42 write the
2 down here and then the 4 which
represents 40 I can put in the tens
place 7 times 3 is 21 plus 4 is 25 so I
could write the 25 right over here
there's no place to carry this 2 so I
just wrote the 2 right over here in the
hundreds place now let's move over so
let me clean this up so we don't get
confused so we just figured out what 7
times 36 is it is 252
now let's worry about what 36 times 20
is and so what we're going to do is
we're going to throw a 0 right over here
because we're now going to multiply 36
times something in the tens place this
isn't just a 2 this is a 20 so 2 or I
should say well let's just go with the
digits right now and then we'll think
about it
in terms of place value in the second
time around 2 times 6 is 12 right the 2
right over here carry the 1 2 times 3 is
6 plus 1 is 7 so we just figured out
that 36 times 20 is 720 and just think
about what would have happened if we
didn't put this 0 here then we would
have figured out that 36 times 2 is 72
but this 2 isn't just a 2 this is a 20
so 36 times 20 is 720 and now we can add
these two things because 36 times 27 is
the same thing as 36 times 20
Plus 36 times 7 so let's add these two
numbers together to type 2 Plus 0 is 2 5
plus 2 is 7 2 plus 7 is 9 and we get 972
now I'm going to do this exact same
problem again but this time this time
I'm going to really talk about what
these digits represent hopefully the
first pass you kind of saw the process
for doing it now we're going to think
about what these digits actually
represent so we're going to multiply 36
times 7 so 7 times 6 is 42 we would
write the 2 in the ones place and then
the 40 we can write in the tens places 4
represents 47 times 30 is 210 plus 40 is
250 250 and we already had that 2 in the
ones way so we get 250 to 36 times 7 is
252 now let's clean this up now let's
multiply 20 20 times 6 is going to give
us 120 so let's write the 20 in the tens
place and then carry the 100 or carry
the 1 which represents 100 now 2 times
or I should say 20 times 30 is going to
give you 600 plus 1 more hundred is
going to give you 700 is going to give
you 700 so we just figured out that 36
times 20 is 720 the 7 is the hundreds
place 2 in the tens place and then we
can add again and just like we did the
last time we got we got 972